[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight within minutes of the
parkland Florida massacre our media
identified a villain it wasn't the 19
year old who actually pulled the trigger
CNN actually published a piece last
night scolding the president for calling
him crazy that was a slur according to
them you know the real killer the media
told us was the NRA along with millions
of law-abiding gun owners blood was on
their hands well a few days later now
that we have some facts it turns out
it's not so simple it turns out that
government at all levels played a role
in allowing this Massacre to happen in
fact a much larger role than we knew or
ever would have guessed the details are
shocking here's part of what we've
learned so far the Broward County
Sheriff's Office received at least 23
calls related to Nicholas Cruz and his
family in 2016 a deputy was told
directly that Cruz was threatening to
shoot up his school the one he shot up
and had taken photographs of himself
with firearms that information was
forwarded to deputy Scott Peterson that
name sounds familiar that is the exact
security guard at Stoneman Douglas High
School who hid outside during the
shooting and refused to go inside as 17
people were murdered apparently doing
nothing was a habit of Peterson's
president Trump weighed in on him today
on his way to CPAC watch when it came
time to get in there and do something he
didn't have the courage or something
happen but he certainly did a poor job
there's no question about that
he was there for five minutes the five
minutes that was during the entire
shooting he heard it right at the
beginning so he certainly did a poor job
but that's a case where somebody was
outside they're trained they didn't
react properly under pressure or there
were coward Scott Peterson may not have
been the only coward on the scene brand
new reports tonight suggests that three
other Broward County deputies arrived at
the school during the massacre but did
not enter or attempt to pursue Cruz
instead they hid outside behind their
vehicles until Coral Springs police
officers arrived and found them in
action appears to be a defining quality
in the Broward County Sheriff
office last November Broward County was
warned that Cruz was a school shooter in
the making and was collecting weapons
with which to do it
they didn't even write a report on the
tip and instead they told the tipster to
report Cruz to the pom beef Beach County
Sheriff's Office
that's how local police responded or
didn't respond the state wasn't much
better later in 2016 despite evidence of
suicidal behavior by Cruz and his
expressed desire to buy a firearm the
Florida Department of Children and
Families decided that somehow he was not
a threat to himself or others if they
decided otherwise Cruz Cruz would have
been involuntarily committed and would
have been barred from buying a gun so in
case you're wondering how was this guy
able to buy a gun that's how and then
there's the FBI the feds in September
2017 the FBI was warned that a YouTube
user named Nicholas Cruz spelled
correctly had written this quote I'm
going to be a professional school
shooter he wrote that online the FBI now
says that was not enough information to
identify who made that remark and they
were unable to investigate despite the
fact that Cruz gave his real name
spelled in the unusual way that it is
spelt in January 2018 the FBI was warned
again that Cruz was planning to shoot up
a school and were given specific
information about his erratic behavior
his gun collecting his expressed desire
to kill people he did not hide that the
tipster warned that Cruz was quote going
to explode and worried it was just a
matter of time before he quote was in a
school and shooting the place up the
scholar also told the FBI that she made
the call because she wanted a quote
clear conscience
if he takes off and just starts shooting
places up in response the FBI did
nothing they didn't even bother to
forward that tip to their Miami field
office so it died the school system
failed as well and badly in 2013 school
officials decided to radically cut down
on in-school arrests claiming that
school discipline was racially biased
the school simply stopped referring
students to police for assault and drug
use and numerous other crimes actual
crimes total arrests declined for more
than a thousand a year to fewer than 400
so in spite of getting in trouble with
school authorities repeatedly Cruz was
never arrested he was never charged
never convicted never stopped from
buying a gun
the school's failed the local police
failed the Florida State bureaucracy
failed the officer on duty failed the
FBI failed the government's first duty
is protecting its citizens they failed
ultimately citizens have to defend
themselves the message could not be
clearer and yet the same government
officials who failed to protect us are
saying we don't have a right to protect
ourselves